Now that we know that we can
treat units algebraically,
let's see if we can
use that knowledge
to figure out what the
units of a variable
might be from some formula.
So let's say that I am given
this formula, that capital K is
equal to lowercase
b over s squared.
And let's say that
we are also told
that b is going to
be in centimeters,
and s is going to be in
grams per centimeter.
So that's the units of s
is grams per centimeter.
B is in centimeters.
What is the units
of K going to be?
And I encourage you
to pause this video
and think about this.
Well, let's try it out with
just some value and some values
for b and s, and
see what happens.
Let's say that b is
equal to 1 centimeter,
and I'm just using 1, because
it makes the math really easy.
And let's say that s is
1 gram per centimeter.
So, we know that
K is going to be
equal to 1 centimeter-- that's
b-- over 1 gram per centimeter
squared.
Now, we've already
talked about the idea
that we should treat our units
like algebraic quantities,
so this should be equal to
1 centimeter over-- now,
you could treat this
as 1 squared times--
let me rewrite this.
You could rewrite this
as 1 squared times grams
per centimeter squared, and
this just comes out of the idea
that if I have a
times b to some power,
say, the second power, that's
equal to a squared b squared.
And we also know that if I
have a/b to some power, say,
squared, that's the same thing
as a squared over b squared.
So I could rewrite
this as this is
going to be equal to 1
centimeter over-- 1 squared is
just 1-- 1 gram squared
per centimeter squared.
Now, what is this
going to be equal to?
Let me write it over here.
Well, that's going to be 1
centimeter in our numerator.
Let me do it in that
green color, just
to keep track of things.
1 centimeter from our numerator,
instead of dividing it
by 1 gram squared
centimeter squared,
I can multiply it times
the reciprocal of this.
So times 1/1, which
is just going to be 1,
but let me just
write it that way
just so that you get that I'm
taking the reciprocal of 1.
So 1/1 times the reciprocal of
grams squared per centimeter
squared.
Well, that's just
going to be centimeters
squared per grams squared.
So what's this going
to be equal to?
Well, I have 1 times 1, so if I
take the numeric parts, 1 times
1, it's just going to be 1.
And now remember, we can
treat the units algebraically.
I have a centimeters
times centimeters squared.
Well, that's going to get me to
centimeters cubed, centimeters
to the third power.
And this isn't c times
n to the third power.
This is centimeters
to the third power--
or you could write
it like this if you
wanted to be clear about it--
per-- and over here we still
have grams squared--
per grams squared.
So the units, I just picked
the numbers 1 arbitrarily,
so the 1 isn't
what matters here.
I just picked those numbers.
What matters here is
what are the units.
What are the units
for this formula when
b is in centimeters and s
is in grams per centimeters?
We see that K is
going to be expressed
in terms of cubic
centimeters per gram squared.
And I can't tell
you offhand kind
of an intuitive physical
representation of that,
but you at least know the units.
You have cubic
centimeters, which
you can view as a volume--
divided by, I guess,
a mass squared.
And a mass squared is a little
bit less intuitive for me,
but at least we know
what the units of K
would be in this formula
given the units of b and s.